foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
covering all the times that Professor
Severus Snape was responsible for saving
Harry Potter while of course it is true
that Snape had little love for the boy
who lived the fact remains that he had a
lot of love for Harry's deceased mum
Lily Potter as anyone who has read or
watched the final movie of the Harry
Potter series will know the whole reason
Severus abandoned his allegiance to the
dark lord in favor of being a double
agent for Albus Dumbledore and the Order
of the Phoenix was indeed his feelings
for Lily a devotion that seemed to only
deepen with her murder committed by
Voldemort himself
in any case in the wake of Lily's death
the only part of her that lived on was
of course her son Harry unfortunately
for Harry and Snape are both the boy was
also a concert reminder to Severus that
Lily had chosen a life and partner who
wasn't him that partner was of course
James Potter who had been a pair of both
Severus and Lily at Hogwarts and who had
spent years tormenting Snape so what
does this leave us with we know that
Snape likely felt incredibly torn of his
feelings for the young Harry Potter when
he finally arrived at Hogwarts eleven
years after his beloved Lily had been
murdered alongside her husband whom he
loathed at the hands of his former
master who he had betrayed in an attempt
to save Lily only to have her die and
Voldemort disappear
I mean that's enough conflicting
feelings to make anyone act a little
bizarrely don't you think and so it
actually makes quite a bit of sense as
to why Severus would have protected
Harry from Mortal danger so often while
also proclaiming hatred for the boy this
of course leads us to all the times that
Severus Snape saved Harry Potter despite
his Surly disposition in doing so 1.
counter-cursing Harry's jinxed broom in
the Philosopher's Stone during Harry's
very first Quidditch game his his
broomstick becomes jinxed flinging Harry
about high up in the air the Jinx very
well could have thrown him off his
broomstick and to his death
fortunately Snape realizes these
circumstances and mutters counter curses
under his breath throughout the entirety
of the match
recognizing that the same danger May
await Harriet the following match Snape
even goes so far to protect Harry that
he serves as referee in gryffindor's
next Quidditch game 2. teaching Harry
Expelliarmus in the Chamber of Secrets
when guildway Lockhart puts on his
short-lived dueling Club Snape teaches
Harry how to perform the expelliarma
spell obviously this instruction doesn't
directly save Harry at this exact point
in time however Mr Potter goes on to use
this spell so often in favor of more
offensive and dangerous curses that it's
often referred to as his signature spell
of course being that it is a defensive
spell that helps the witch or wizard who
issues it deflect harmful curses it
stands to reason that every time Harry
goes on to use Expelliarmus is a time
that Severus Snape has indirectly saved
his life 3. casting vipera evanesca to
protect Harry
during those same sessions of the
dueling Club in the Chamber of Secrets
Snape also comes to Harry's Aid when
Malfoy conjures up a snake while dueling
Harry unaware that Harry is indeed a
parcel tongue meaning that he could have
communicated with the conjured serpent
the professor cast The Snake Vanishing
spell the pera aveneska in order to
protect Harry from harm
4. intervening on the night of a full
moon the next major moment when Severus
Snape comes to Harry's Aid is in the
Prisoner of Azkaban near the end of this
installment not only does Snape Place
himself between Harry and the perceived
danger that his serious black he also
follows Remus Lupine out of Hogwarts
after he realizes that the latter
Professor has forgotten to take his wolf
Spain potion which of course is the very
thing keeping Lupine from transitioning
to a dangerous werewolf during the full
moon in doing so Snape is able to save
Harry Ron and Hermione from Lupine
attacking them after transforming
5. giving instruction on occlimency of
course one of the most well-known
instances of Snape attempting to help
Harry is when he provides the boy with
occlimency lessons these lessons are
given with the sole intention of
assisting Harry with the ability to
close his mind to Lord Voldemort a skill
that could very well save his life
unfortunately despite efforts that let's
be honest were less than their best
these sessions resulted in very little
progress and mostly revealed their
feelings of animosity towards one
another
6. providing a fake Veritas serum potion
in the Order of the Phoenix Harry is up
against the Despicable Dolores Umbridge
a new professor at Hogwarts whose overly
sweet demeanor is nothing more than a
facade for what some may call Pure Evil
in fact at one point in his fifth
installment of the series she implores
Severus for help in interrogating Harry
yes she was interrogating students by
requesting that Snape make her the truth
serum verita serum now not only does
Snape put her off and prolong the making
of the potion but he also gives her a
fake verita serum in order to protect
Harry from being subjected to the
effects of the potion thereby also
helping him conceal the location of
Sirius Black and the safe house of the
Order of the Phoenix 7. alerting the
order to Harry's disappearance when
Harry disappears in a dark Forest near
the end of the Order of the Phoenix
Professor Snape goes after
upon realizing that Harry is no longer
on Hogwarts grounds he alerts the order
sending them to the ministry of magic in
London in an effort to protect Harry
from pursuing Death Eaters 8. allowing
Harry to keep his potions textbook of
course everyone knows by the end of the
sixth installment of the series The
half-bud Prince that Severus Snape is
the self-proclaimed Half Blood Prince as
he explains to Harry he's a Half-Blood
wizard whose mother's maiden name was
Prince what we don't know is why Snape
would have enabled Harry to use his
potion Sex book which contained zebras's
detailed notes and thus he was purposely
wanting to help Harry without helping
Harry if you know what I mean Snape
undoubtedly knew that Harry was using
his old textbook since he alludes to
this at several points in the narrative
and finally accuses him of using his own
spells against him at the end of the
order this suggests that Snape was
allowing Harry to leverage his nodes
which ultimately helped Harry uncover
the truth about Voldemort's horcruxes a
vital step in helping Harry and the
others get closer to defeating the dark
lord 9. saving Harry from committing
murder in the same book or film
depending on your preference Snape also
prevents Harry from committing a heinous
crime after Harry uses one of Snape's
spells from his old potions textbook to
attack Malfoy Draco nearly dies if
Professor Snape hadn't healed Malfoy's
extensive injuries Harry would have been
guilty of murder which undoubtedly would
have affected his character as well as
his moral and mental state
10. stopping Death Eaters from killing
Harry
one of the most direct examples of Snape
saving Harry's life is when he stops
Voldemort's Death Eaters from killing
him on the pretense that Harry must be
saved for the dark lord himself of
course why he didn't allow them to then
capture Harry and take him directly to
Voldemort seems quite suspicious but
kudos to Severus for pulling this off
11. the idea of decoy Potters by the
seventh installment of the series Snape
has had to fully integrate himself into
Voldemort's good graces and disguise his
true allegiance to the Order of the
Phoenix So Undercover was Snape at this
point in the story that no one other
than Professor Dumbledore's sentient
portrait in the headmaster's office at
Hogwarts was aware of the incredible
risks he was taking to help protect
Harry's life
one of the most notable examples of this
is the fact that he knew that Voldemort
was aware of the date the order would be
transferring Harry to the safety of
number 12 grumbled planks of course he
couldn't simply tell members of the
order since everyone was under the
impression that he was a murderous
traitor so he Charmed madungas Fletcher
into sharing the idea of multiple decoy
Potters so as to help Harry have the
best chance of survival
12. providing the Sword of Gryffindor
instructed by the sentient portrait of
Albus Dumbledore Snape plants The Sword
of Gryffindor in a lake nearby the camp
that Harry and Hermione have made in
order to lure him to the location Snape
cast his Patronus that of a doe which
Harry Associates with his stag Patronus
of course providing Harry with this
weapon capable of destroying horcruxes
isn't so much of an act of saving Harry
as it is assisting him in taking down
Voldemort however you could make the
argument that by helping Harry destroy
one of the Dark Lord's horcruxes he is
helping Harry get that much closer to
eradicating the threat that is Voldemort
who is of course a constant threat on
Harry's life that said a more concrete
Act of saving Harry directly follows
Severus does not leave the lake until he
ensures that Harry is safely retrieved
from the Water by Ron
13. final instructions on how to defeat
Voldemort the 13th and final instance at
least by my count of Severus Snape
helping save Harry is when he shares his
memories with him before dying near the
end of the Deathly Hallows these
memories not only absolve Snape of his
guilt in the death of Dumbledore they
also explain his feelings for Harry's
mother why he disliked Harry's father
and most importantly how Harry can
finally defeat Voldemort of course in
defeating the dark lord Harry discovers
that he must sacrifice himself which I
suppose you could argue is not so much
saving Harry as instructing him to die
but in the end Harry's sacrifice does
not prove to be the end of his life so
without Severus sharing this crucial
detail and how to overcome Voldemort
Harry would not have been able to defeat
him and come through alive and well or
well enough on the other side and with
that we've come to the end of another
video what do you think did I miss any
other obvious instances of snape-saving
Harry or perhaps you don't agree with
one please share your thoughts in the
comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember the mind is not a
book to be opened at will and examined
at leisure
foreign